nous avons décidé de dissoudre la
Constitution nous tenons à informer la
population que la situation est sous
contrôle ils ont mis le pays au-dessus
du Mali d'abord
ancien légionnaire de l'armée française
colonel dans l'armée guinéenne
commandant du groupement des forces
spéciales
Ibrahim Traoré 35 ans formé à l'Académie
militaire Georges Namu moineau de Pau
capitaine dans l'armée
burkinabèta 40 ans formé au Britannique
militaire de Cathy colonel dans l'armée
malienne commandant les forces spéciales
maliennes ils sont trois ils sont de la
même génération et ils ont chacun fait
un coup d'État dans leur pays 3
militaires qui dirigent un gouvernement
de transition et qui à terme doivent
organiser des élections mais la question
que tout le monde se pose aujourd'hui
c'est est-ce qu'ils vont y arriver et
surtout est-ce qu'ils le feront
la transition c'est une courte durée
il y a trop de défis
à relever
beaucoup d'entente et tout le monde veut
au moins son problème soit résolu
pendant cette transition c'est pas
possible je suis jeune au même titre que
vous et si je joue c'est toute la
jeunesse maligne par définition comme le
dit le président malien une transition
est courte Gotha Doumbia et Traoré ont
dévoilé des chronogrammes et promis des
élections en 2024 aujourd'hui on est
dans les transitions qui sont qui sont
délicates qui sont indéterminés dans les
trois pays il y a quand même beaucoup de
on a beaucoup de mal à avancer dans le
calendrier des réformes
institutionnelles il y a très peu de
consensus en fait politique interne pour
avancer ils n'en prennent pas le chemin
au Mali à une constitution qui a été
taillée sur mesure
en Guinée et encore une hésitation sur
la suite au Burkina Faso la dernière
fois qu'il a fait une interview il a
déclaré que les élections les conditions
pour les élections ne sont pas prêtes
d'ailleurs on le voit très bien par le
passé quand on avait des la pression de
la et des militaires qui devaient passer
le pouvoir il faisait les transitions
d'un an de justement maximum on a encore
en tête ces gens de transition mais
quand la transition s'allonge c'est sûr
que le détenteur du pouvoir n'entend pas
le laisser alors je pense qu'ils vont
évidemment y arriver parce que on est
quand même dans des volontés de
régulation il y a des des politiques des
civils qui participent dans les trois
pays aux efforts de la transition donc
on n'est pas dans un système de jantes
c'est pas le Nigéria des années du début
des années 90 donc les concepts de
jointe de pucciste sont là aussi à
relativiser puisque il y a une
participation de la société civile
certes les activités politiques sont
très limitées voire interdites mais il
s'agit selon moi de mettre en avant la
recherche d'un nouveau modèle cela
passera sans doute par des formes d'État
généraux de confiance nationale de
référendum constitutionnel
au cours desquels les populations seront
amenées à se prononcer
tout comme je ne crois pas au Burkina
Faso tout comme je ne crois pas en
Guinée Conakry dans un contexte comme
celui-ci il peut pas y avoir de
d'élections sans que l'on soit rassuré
de ce que l'élection peut communément et
instantanément être organisé sur le
territoire national et l'aspect
sécuritaire est un sujet
pour y arriver c'est militaires ont un
atout majeur c'est l'aspiration profonde
de la jeunesse au changement et
aujourd'hui c'est que cette jeunesse
demande clairement c'est le
développement et l'indépendance
véritable notamment vis-à-vis de la
France aucunement
[Musique]
parce que notre indépendance notre
souverain cela stipule que certains pays
auront du mal
voulons juste dire le Burkina Faso avec
Thomas Sankara le Mali avec Modibo Keita
la Guinée avec ses couturiers ont tous
une histoire de la souveraineté de la
recherche de la véritable indépendance
de la seconde indépendance donc on est
quand même dans des pays qui ont une
tradition de revendication de leur
souveraineté dans des pays qui veulent
être respectés qui veulent être reconnus
pour ce qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire des
États libres indépendants et souverains
quelle évolution dans la gouvernance
quelle évolution les partis politiques
sont interdits les syndicats sont
interdits en termes de gouvernance c'est
la catastrophe qu'on voit dans ces
paysans dont on me dit que ces coups de
temps à la fois évoluent la gouvernance
quelle est la gouvernance comment au
contraire on va très bien dans ces pays
qui sont victimes de hormis la
France qui sont aujourd'hui les alliés
de ces militaires la Russie la CEDEAO
de nos rapports avec
nos amis nos voisins de la soulagement
en général je dirais que ça se passe
bien
mieux avec d'autres et moins avec
d'autres tout cela crée évidemment
aujourd'hui des situations assez
étranges où on voit des pouvoirs
militaires et porter je dirais comme
porter au mur par la rue considéré comme
étant une réponse
des aspirations nouvelles qui sont des
aspirations assez assez confuse
d'ailleurs où se bouscule à la fois je
dirais un sentiment de souverainisme
inventé de rompre avec ce qui est
considéré comme un lien cordon
ombilical avec l'ancien puissance
coloniale et puis une revendication je
dirais de nouveaux partenariats avec la
Russie pour pour dire les choses très
clairement un besoin je dirais de
ne pas je dirais une adhésion disons
argumenté
à la Russie mais une besoin je dirais de
d'instrumentaliser même la Russie pour
pouvoir contester le le partenaire
traditionnel que la France aujourd'hui
les Alliés suite au Coulibaly c'est
clair c'est c'est la Russie ne s'engage
pas à travers principalement le groupe
acné voilà ils essaient d'aller vers ce
chemin diplomatique la Guinée est quand
même dans un dans un style relativement
différent n'est pas rempli dans une
diatribe elle essaie de garder les
lignes d'une manière ou d'une autre avec
la CEDEAO avec des relations
tumultueuses avec la France tendue avec
la CEDEAO les trois leaders West
africains doivent trouver les
alternatives l'idée d'une fédération
entre les trois pays a été un moment
largement commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux le Mali le Burkina Faso et la
Guinée auront en tout cas prouvé avec le
coup d'État au Niger qui serait prêt à
allier leurs forces ils ont
officiellement affiché leur soutien au
pouvoir militaire au Niger et au même
mis en garde la CEDEAO contre toute
tentative d'intervention armée